so eagles carson wentz
fought they finally pulled in for jalen
hurts yesterday
doug peterson who may or may not be on
the hot seat
um there is a question
and a discussion going on internally but
no decision at least none that he's
ready to announce as to who is going to
start
the next game hertz looked uh
if i could say one word by comparison to
carson
hurts at least look comfortable now
you know backup quarterbacks come in
different skill set oh we weren't
prepared for him i get it
you know he looked comfortable and he
looked more competent
frankly than carson has looked in quite
some time so
while not everything is at the feet of
carson wins
offensive line issues play calling wide
receivers
all i know is jalen hurts had the same
situation
and he looked better i don't know how
you don't start jalen hurts moving
forward or at least next week
and secondarily michael i'm not sure if
you believe what you read about
the fact that nick foles had been in
carson wentz's head
and the drafting of jalen hurts is also
in his head according to reports
i'm not sure how carson wentz
recovers from this in the near future
i'm not writing him off for the rest of
his career
but not just near future but in
philadelphia
okay how does he recover from this in
philadelphia
i have them i have on my feed
it's not you it's them carson
and i believe that it's not you carson
it's them let me tell you this mike uh
i'm gonna try to make money for some
people i'm gonna try to
because because i'm kind that way i'm
generous
i'm trying to put some more money in
people's pockets this is not
my bet your money by the way three and
oh
but who's keeping score stop it
i'm gonna try to help some people make
some money yeah three and a half this is
a season record
what's your season record over five okay
better than the eagles sure about that
you sure about that no
no okay okay if you are if you
are a front office type who has ever
been a part of a super bowl champion and
then gotten that team in a
in a good position the following year
the following years
maybe back to the super bowl uh winning
the super bowl back there back to the
conference championship game
i got some money for you because this is
the number one
uh whole uh this is uh where a lot of
teams
just are deficient in how to build a
team
after you win a super bowl and that's
the problem with the philadelphia eagles
they won the super bowl they weren't
really sure
how to proceed going forward one of the
things and i don't blame them okay one
of the reasons
they were kind of throwing off mike is
that their
super bowl mvp was their backup
quarterback
so yeah that's that's that's not the
script that's that's
that's not okay you know what does this
mean what's giants phil sims
you know jeff hosteller but yeah that
typically doesn't happen that way carson
wentz is our guy we're going to say that
but do we believe it do we believe it
was it really nick foles yeah think
about some of the roster decisions
that they made some something draft and
receiver
they're terrible at drafting receivers
nick foles you gotta let him go okay
nick foles you gotta move on from nick
foles
uh chris long retired uh
all right or probably retired or went to
another team all right that's fine
um they lost malcolm jenkins that's
leadership
um they've done a really bad job
of drafting wide receivers
their offensive line is broken down they
just have they
just have not built the organization all
the way around the organization
has not operated like a championship
organization and then then you sound
surprised
when oh carson wentz doesn't look the
same oh you know something's missing
from carson yeah something's missing
from carson
but something is missing from this
entire this entity
i'm not laying every whole thing would
be it's unintelligent
it's unintelligent to watch what carson
wentz was
watch the circumstances in philadelphia
right now
and to lay the blame for their struggles
at the quarterback we've talked about
this we talked about this at nauseam
that's not my concern michael
it's not about i'm not trying to assign
blame i'm looking forward
and i'm saying regardless of how they
got here
my concern is that they've ruined him at
least in philadelphia
thankfully we've seen quarterbacks go
through worse and then they go somewhere
else
and and they turn their career around he
may not be able to go anywhere given how
much of a of of of an investment of
financial investment the eagles have
made it their way he may be stuck like
chuck
maybe but he may be stuck like chuck and
it may behoove them
to figure out how to fix him given that
we saw how great he can be
but is that guy is that day dead do they
even roll like that anymore dawg because
it's like
if if if nick foles and now jaylen hurts
his really
in his head it might michael look man
if jalen hurts was in his head when they
drafted him
but jalen hurts to go in there and even
in limited duty against the
against the packers looked better than
he did
and if doug peterson starts jalen hurts
and under those same circumstances jalen
hurts balls out
that is a mind job for carson wentz
who i don't know the young man seems
like a nice dude yeah but
by based on this sounds like he's
already fragile
how do you put that back together so
regardless of whose thought it is
he needs to be fixed from the neck up in
particular
okay there there there are two ways of
looking at this thing
and one of them is what you just said
all right so you could say
hey if the organization is doing all
these things
and you're bothered by it you're
affected by it some people might say
that individual is fragile yeah but not
me
enough no new new
i'm gonna say oh i'm fixing america
today man i'm feeling good i'm feeling
pretty
listen i got all the answers as i sit
here in my living room talking with you
i got all the answers to the world and
and
you know it's it's probably
none of it none of it makes sense but it
makes sense to me
uh i'm telling you i would do it this
way
i would talk to carson oh amazing talk
to carson wentz this is a communication
issue this is not about him being soft
or him being fragile this is about an
organization
not explaining to him what what this
is about it's just okay you can't sit
there
and make moves and then when you haven't
explained them
to the employee say well what's wrong
with the employee
what's wrong with the employees they got
a bad boss they got a bad communicator
right somebody looking at it that's one
way of looking it happens it happens
all it happens in every industry
but i i just yes i'm not saying i just
want to make sure i'm clear on something
you kind of
sound like you would say a soft slash
fragile i'm not saying he's soft but i'm
not even saying he's inherently fragile
you said practice but the moves that
they have made as an organization
michael to your point
have him in a fragile state at least
based on what you're reading and maybe
even seeing
but ultimately still his job to go out
and perform
and if the other guy's performing better
they gotta play
hey thanks for watching brother from
another on youtube make sure you hit
subscribe before you leave and be sure
to watch us
3 to 5 pm eastern time on peacock
appreciate you